[Música]
economía en directo América de Francia
24 Jorge buena mañana de jueves también
terminó hoy la reunión de los banqueros
centrales del mundo
celebrando celebrado en Portugal esta
reunión que dijeron los banqueros fueron
tres días de foro organizado por el
Banco Central europeo y ahí la pregunta
central era Cómo enfrentamos la
inflación global sin causar una recesión
económica en el mundo durante el foro
los dirigentes de la reserva Federal
estadounidense Fed El Banco Central
europeo y el banco de Inglaterra dijeron
estar decididos a controlar esta
inflación por ejemplo lloran Powell
presidente de la affet de Estados Unidos
dijo que su meta es devolver la
inflación al objetivo del Banco Central
que era del 2% y usará las herramientas
a su alcance En referencia a propósito
de subir los tipos de interés como lo ha
venido haciendo los últimos meses la Fed
subió los tipos de intereses 75 puntos
básicos este mes fue el mayor aumento
desde 1994 y señaló que podría hacerlo
nuevamente en este mes de julio que
entra en esa misma línea Cristina
presidenta del Banco Central europeo
aseguró que esperan Volver al objetivo
Aunque la inflación en Europa se
mantiene en niveles altos el emisor
europeo ya anunció su vida de tipos de
interés en julio y septiembre escuchemos
parte de esa discusión
nuestra misión nuestro mandato nuestro
trabajo es proporcionar estabilidad de
precios que hemos definido en el 2%. Así
que actualmente tenemos una previsión de
inflación del 6,8% para este año bajando
al 3,5% y al 2,1% en 2024 todo ello está
por encima del objetivo durante todo el
periodo de proyección y tenemos que
hacer lo que tenemos que hacer que es
devolverla al 2% y así lo haremos
bueno Jorge Vamos a darle seguimiento a
la guerra en Ucrania Pero por supuesto
desde el lado económico el gigante ruso
gastroma no pagará los dividendos y es
la primera vez que no lo hace desde 1998
y causó que sus acciones cayeran en más
del
27%. los accionistas decidieron que en
la situación actual con la guerra no es
recomendable pagar dividendos en función
de los resultados de 2021 según dijo el
director general adjunto familia agregó
que la empresa debe centrarse en la
gasificación de las regiones rusas la
preparación de la temporada de
calefacción y el pago de mayores
impuestos esta situación se da cuando
ocurren dos momentos importantes Raúl
uno cuando las potencias económicas del
g7 quieren limitar el precio del
petróleo y el gas ruso como sanción por
su invasión a Ucrania y cuando los
flujos del gas ruso hacia Europa a
través de Ucrania y del gasoducto
nordstring 1 También han caído
significativamente Jorge y nos vamos
hasta China y le pregunto cómo
evoluciona la economía allí luego de los
cierres por la pandemia de Kobe 19 bueno
China reportó un fuerte repunto de los
servicios y la construcción publicó su
índice de gerente de compras divulgado
por la oficina Nacional de estadísticas
la industria manufacturera de China
volvió a crecer en junio Después de tres
meses consecutivos de contracción a
causa de estas restricciones impuestas
para controlar
19 o su famosa política 0 el indicador
de referencia del sector manufacturero
marcó este mes 50,2. frente a los 49,6
que había marcado en abril el centro
financiero de Shanghai levantó como
sabemos su bloqueo de dos meses a
principios de junio permitiendo la
reapertura de más comercio de la
renovación de la producción de las
fábricas y también la recuperación de
las operaciones portuarias pero hay que
tener cautela dicen los expertos porque
este repunto del sector manufacturero
fue a un débil porque hubo retrasos en
la demanda vamos a con Ecuador Jorge
América Latina en ese país está buscando
un diálogo para resolver las protestas
pero el sector petrolero ha sido uno de
los mayores afectados con toda esta
revuelta social de hecho la agencia
calificadora muris dice que la ganancias
que podría tener este país en el sector
petrolero a propósito de los altos
precios del petróleo a nivel mundial
pues van a dejar de ser percibidas
precisamente por esta presión política
que se vive según la agencia no hay en
la gobernabilidad y la agenda política
del gobierno encontrará más obstáculos
según muris la reducción de 10 centavos
en los combustibles que anunció el
gobierno para tratar de apaciguar las
protestas le costará al Estado 230
millones de dólares Lo que equivale al
0,2% del producto interno bruto de ese
país el presidente Guillermo lasso
enfrenta su mayor reto político a un año
de estar en el poder lazo pide el cese
de la violencia y desconoce el liderazgo
de leónidas Isa del movimiento indígena
ayer se convocó a un nuevo intento de
diálogo con la Iglesia Católica como
mediadora escuchemos
exhortamos a todas las partes en
conflicto que en función de la
aceptación que ahora ha dado el gobierno
a esta mediación no se produzcan más
brotes ni actos de violencia ni durante
la noche ni durante las tempranas horas
de la mañana porque eso podría
eventualmente también complicar que este
proceso de mediación avance necesitamos
concluir con este diálogo este diálogo
está puesto una pausa para poder
concretar lo que en la mesa estaba
avanzando Jorge gracias por toda la
información de economía en la segunda
hora más economía por supuesto Vamos a
darle paso a sumar esa para hablar de
deportes
[Música]